what was Dyson thinking this is really
one of the most interesting pair of cans
quite literally this thing looks like a
pair of cans the Dyson Zone absolute
plus that you can only get through Dyson
directly comes in a Prussian Blue and
the colorway is beautiful but that aside
we need to address the elephant two
elephants in the room does it sound good
actually yes they are more decent than I
thought they would be they sound great
and we will touch more on that later on
how do I feel about wearing this in
public
not so great sure they're meant to help
you get cleaner air by filtering and
funneling it through this bit down here
but I could not physically bring myself
to where this are in public
but I did anyway which you will be
seeing throughout this video in Clips I
did use it in a public toilet when the
ammonia was stinging and the Dyson Zone
filter that nastiness and fed it back in
and the air smells like a brand new car
but is all of this worth the Hefty price
stack of us 1949 we'll find out I do
need to say I will be reviewing whether
these headphones are actually viable and
functional and how well they perform for
the most part so we're talking about
paper performance mostly the differences
between the normal Dyson Zone and the
app store plus which we have down here
are the accessories you receive it's
colorway and the availability you can
get the regular Dyson Zone through
retailers at Kerry Dyson but again the
Dyson Zone absolute plus can only be
bought directly from Dyson what you get
in the box is a carrying case solely for
the headphones and its accessories there
is a USBC charging cable a 3.5
millimeter cable and Anthony adapter a
strap or rope to carry the case around
the headphones which explains the size
of the case it's visor which in this
colorway really reminds me of Pacific
Rims Gypsy danger there's no way I'm the
only one that sees that it's either that
or Soldier 76. a soft pouch for the
headphones a visor sleeve for the visor
the advisor cleaning brush and lastly
for filters they are electrostatic
filters that Dyson says captures 99 of
particle pollutions as small as 0.1
microns and K carbon potassium and Rich
carbon filters for city pollution before
we get into it this channel is supported
by Brands who help us improve our
content and keep us going so stay around
for this sponsored message meet the
Cyber 15 gaming laptop from MSI check
out this translucent material design
that not only looks good but feels good
thanks to its Ultra lightweight chassis
at only 1.98 kilograms give yourself the
upper Edge in gaming with its blazing
fast performance powered by the latest
12th gen Intel Core i7 hch processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its the hibic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com you essentially get an
extra pale filters that lasts up to a
full year depending on the city you live
in say it will last a year in Singapore
our air here is relatively clean all
around but possibly four to six months
in cities like Jakarta Indonesia the
number of Mines gets lower or higher
depending on the quality of air in the
city you may either live or work in
these filters are placed inside the cans
themselves because these sides are where
the air gets sucked in to get filtered
the Dyson Zone costs U.S 949 while the
absolute plus costs us
1999.99 let's talk specs real quick the
specs 40 millimeter 16 ohm new damium
drivers on both sides noise canceling
goes up to 38 decibels there are 11
microphones in total eight of which 80
noise cancellation 50 hours of battery
life of low Distortion audio there are
controls on the headphones there is a
button on the left ear cup that controls
the fan speed modes and the Bluetooth on
the right cup there is a small joystick
that pauses plays skips and goes to
previous tracks it also controls the
volume you can tap twice on the side of
either cup to enable transparent NC and
ENC modes a note on the battery life if
you do plan to use the air purification
system on your commute it will last
about 4 hours depending on the speed of
the fan you have set them on so it will
last you pretty much your entire commute
to and from work but not much more than
that unless you're feeling lucky a note
on the fan speeds there is also an auto
mode that adjusts the fan speed
according to how quick you're moving so
if you're jogging or running with these
the fan speeds will increase and when
you do reach a standstill it will
decrease so they do adapt your situation
provided they are on auto mode okay so
this is how it sounds like when the fans
are on for the Dyson
so
speed one
okay it sounds like this
speed two
and speed three
and the air gets funneled in through the
visor here through little slits on this
side of the cans
speaking of running or jogging in public
that also depends on whether you can
stomach wearing the whole thing in
public I mean sure some of you do not
care about getting looks and understand
that it's just human to look or stare at
something that looks so unique and out
of the ordinary but a lot of people
would still prefer to keep a low profile
and avoid standing out which leads me to
this point where I am of the opinion
that the Pfizer should really be kept to
situational usage the train you are on
smells bad buys her up stuck in the
toilet with ammonia experience nostrils
maybe visor up all men fart in front of
you that really happened I sure hope you
have your visor up now I am using these
on my commute to work I have some notes
the visor is pretty large and it will
cover your face and limit your field of
view to put it in a way that we all
understand if you're not confident about
walking up or down a set of stairs
without looking at the steps the advisor
thing would not be for you the visor
does not cover or form a seal on your
face so in no way is this a mask like
the LG purk V2 that we reviewed right
here on the top right if you want to
check it out it just filters the air
around you and gets funneled in with
this visor I think in this time where
personal and public health concerns are
still high or have become a priority for
many wash your hands and butts please I
am begging you'd still be better off
wearing a mask and using your headphones
it would be so cool if the next
iteration of this is basically a high
altitude low orbit or Halo mask so I
have some matte black on and I would get
that off the bat right and if you're
into techware or raving I am sure this
would be a perfect fit for your drip the
headphones who would have thought they
would bang at all no they do not Auto
calibrate ANC pressure like the Sony
xm5s but they do work sort of okay with
canceling all high frequencies thanks to
its eight microphones and its ear cups
though you still pick up train Chimes
the sound of the train traveling through
tunnels and higher pitch voices its
earcones are very comfortable they are
not made of any variant leather so do
not worry about it peeling or flaking
also Dyson will be selling replacements
for these two once they get nasty but I
have noticed that noise does leak out
when you do blast music on it so take
note of that back to the ANC stuff you
can't really hear the fans even on the
highest level if you're playing music or
the loudest volume especially so with
more aggressive music like hardcore and
metal though if you're listening to
mellower stuff such as Indie pop or even
podcasts you will hear the fans working
a little other than that more than
decent ANC that doesn't make you feel
like your hit is going to pop sound
quality is surprisingly great there is a
lot of details in the Heights and mids
and the bass is Punchy where it matters
whether I'm listening to mellower pop
tricks like Taylor Swift's acoustic
rendition of lavender Hayes or Phoebe
Bridges savior complex I know I can
count on those headphones to put those
details on the strings and bass guitars
or double basses on emphasis brightly
more electronic and bassier tracks like
that it's a phobia play out really well
it's huge Ruby sound translates great
with the Dyson Zone the base is Uber
Punchy and you can push that up in with
your bass boosted EQ option will get
into the app in a bit rest assured these
headphones exceed my expectations and
it's super fun to put them on and listen
to whatever you want help use it for
gaming if you want to they work well
enough to give you enough information to
know where your enemies are coming from
and here comes the kicker I can get the
same or slightly better audio quality
from my much older xm3s with more
control of the EQ and whatnot Dyson has
the data and signs the backup and drive
the r d for audio development yes but
this is their first four into the market
and hopefully it won't be their last
they sound good but there are better
options out there for cheaper especially
these Sony xm3s the headphones are
pretty hefty at 595 grams without the
visor and 670 grams with the visor the
funny thing is that the airport Max
weighs 385 grams almost half the weight
of the Dyson zone between the two I'll
go with the Dyson Zone any day because
they got the weight distribution right
besides the three cushion areas which
are here here and here on the headband
they place the batteries on these sides
of the headphone bands now most
headphone batteries are stored in the
cans themselves but Dyson is pretty
smart for putting them up here I put
them on for three hours straight and
that three hour mark was when they felt
like they were weighing my ears down the
headband locks in well so they don't
move around a lot when I shift my head
plus the clamping force with these won't
affect you as much I barely feel it
whenever I'm wearing them now for the
app it is cool that the headphones
measure the air quality and volume
around you in real time in these graphs
so again in my opinion if you see that
green turned into red or something else
for the air quality that's when you bust
out the visor the EQ options are well
there you've got an enhanced setting
that places emphasis on treble and a
slight emphasis on myths bass boosted
that follows the same graph as enhanced
but with more emphasis on the bass uh
obviously and neutral a nice almost flat
line with a small hill on the treble you
can't change anything unfortunately I
still wish they had that option for that
at least but the three options work fine
and I found myself on bass boosted
majority of the time oh and while we're
on the phone let's try out the
headphones three microphones that are
dedicated did for calls this is how a b
Dyson Zone sounds like with the two
microphones there are three microphones
in this you made to pick up your voice
for calls and whatnot so this is how it
sounds like and we'll be doing this
without the visor first
okay I'm gonna go put the visor on
go
all right so this is a microphone test
with the visor on and the fans working
we are currently at fan speed one I'm
gonna turn it up a notch and go to
explain speed two real quick
so if you hear the words I'm speaking
right now if you can see what I'm saying
this is basically how it sounds like
when you have the fans turned on right
now at speed two now we're going to
speed three
so essentially you're getting filtered
straight to your mount to the visor and
the microphones are still working at the
same time so
I wonder how it sounds like once I
review this
now that you've heard the microphone in
different settings let me know what you
think about them in the comments below
while I give my final thoughts the Dyson
Zone excels at being a pair of Premium
headphones for consumers out there and
they surprised me in many ways given
that they are the same company that
makes the vacuum cleaner and the fan or
office users they look and sound good
though they're designed with its visor
may not be for everyone that goes
towards air filter technology
integration which again is very new to
the industry and I think with this being
the first iteration of its kind they can
only be more improvements made to its
design and implementation into the
broader market and design philosophies
in good time though it is nice to have
clean air blasting on your face that is
pretty cooling especially on a hot day
again the visor is not a mask and hovers
are on your face so if you really want
to stay safe you'd still be better off
with a normal mask or one that forms a
steel like an n95 other than that they
are deceptively comfortable and 50 hours
of banging audio is a real treat but
again is it worth the US 1949 dollars
all us 1999 and 99 Cents price tag it's
a no for me because I could again buy
another pair headphones and use a mask
but how about you would you get it let
me know in the comments below and make
sure to follow us on all of our socials
here to keep up with the latest news we
put out and if you like what you're
seeing hit the like And subscribe
buttons if it goes a long way with
helping out the channel if you want to
see more stuff check this out
foreign